الاهلي الكولوم مهما مطار
بده يزول لمحل
ان الارض ان الذهب
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم ازمه الخانه الاحمر تعود
الى الواجهه من جديد ومظاهره فلسطينيه
في تصعيد جديده لازمه القضاء في تونس عدد
من القضاه المعزولين يتقدمون بشكو قضائيا
ضد وزيره العدل بسبب عدم تطبيقها قرار
المحكمه الاداريه ايقافه في لقرار عذلهم
ونقابه المحامين تحذروا من خطوره استهداف
المحامين ومحاكمه المدنيين عسكريا
الاف من موظفي خدمه الاسعاف في معظم انحاء
انجلترا ويلز يضربون للمره الثالثه في اقل
من شهرين بعد فشل المحادثات بين نقاباتهم
والحكومه في التوصل الى تسويه بشان تحسين
الاجور وظروف العمل كما يضرب نحو خمسه
الاف موظفيها الصحه في مشفىين حكميين
بمدينه